let's pivot to the pittsburgh steelers
art rooney ii the president of the team
did a conference call with fans recently
and there's a lot of confidence there as
it relates to a 39 year old quarterback
named ben roethlisberger here's what
rooney had to say about him
we wanted ben back uh and the key to it
really was to be able to restructure his
contract
uh in a way that allowed uh us to keep
ben and
and really be able to sign some other
players and uh you know so ben
cooperated with that and was willing to
make some changes in his contract
uh and that allowed us to you know to
keep him on the team for this year which
was always our goal and uh you know
look i i thought ben had a a very good
year last year for somebody that was
coming off our arm surgery and
and uh you know i i think hopefully
he'll have an even
better year this year uh you know with
another year under his belt in terms of
recovering from that arm surgery it was
i'm not quite sure how the steelers got
to the point where they are so confident
that ben roethlisberger is going to be
even better this year he's 39
there were knee issues last year that
they tried to downplay he never showed
up on the injury report with knee
problems there were persistent rampant
reports he had any problems and maybe
it's just arthritic and he's not getting
any treatment so there's no reason to
disclose that he's got the knee issue
but
he he clearly isn't the guy he used to
be and he's going to be a year older i
just don't get
this
this and again this is the time of year
for confidence that borders on delusion
i just don't get it peter i don't know
whether they wanted to give the fans one
last ride with ben rothsberger because
they didn't get it last year i don't
know whether they just want to delay the
point where the band-aid comes off and
they have to find another quarterback
but
i still believe when they get to
november or december one or both sides
is going to regret the last ride of ben
roethlisberger
i hate to say it i agree with you on
that mic and i i hate to see that
because of the great career
roethlisberger has had but
you know look
it if if ben roethlisberger really
rededicates himself and comes back to
training camp in great shape for better
shape than he was in last december i'll
change my thinking on this
but what bothered me down the stretch
for the pittsburgh steelers
is to see look first of all he's a tree
trunk of a quarterback anyway
but when you see what's going on in
football today and how fast football has
become
and you see ben roethlisberger's
inability to get out of the way
uh and and
you know not exclusively but
because he's so heavy or he was so heavy
last year and so that to me is part of
this thing you know he could do he'd do
much better if he was 20 pounds lighter
and he came to camp in pristine
condition
and look he's not one of these guys
who's gonna do the tom brady thing in
the off-season or do the drew brees
thing um and and i just think like
really
and i said this at the time at the end
of the season
if i'm art rooney if i'm mike tomlin
part of my conversation with ben
roethlisberger at the end of the year is
you got to come to camp in better shape
and you got to come to camp lighter you
need to be able to have better
escapability than you did at the end of
last year
and and look hey mike you know what
nobody's talking about in pittsburgh
his biggest security blanket you can
talk about oh antonio brown's gone
le'veon's gone hey
marquise pouncey has been as close
to a quarterback as any center has been
in the nfl
uh in the last decade
and and now that's that security blanket
is gone
who knows what that offensive line is
going to look like and we're just
assuming
that the last three quarters or last two
thirds of last year the running game was
horrible
and because the running game was
horrible oh it's going to be fixed the
steelers always have a great running
game
maybe it will be
but you're changing up an awful lot of
that offense up front
including the guy who was ben
roethlisberger's most
trusted offensive teammate marquise
pouncey
and it creates conflict for the steelers
in the off-season particularly in the
draft are we drafting
guys that will be
developed into great players down the
line or are we trying to plug holes now
for this all-in move to try to make ben
roethlisberger like jerome bettis and
walk off into the sunset with the super
bowl championship and frankly peter i
believe they decided to bring ben back
in part because
they got enough distance from the season
that they were able to go back and look
at what went well look at what didn't go
well and say if we just do this if we
just do this if we just do this we can
win the super bowl
and it got them to kind of get whipped
up into a frenzy that they could pull
this off but they've got a lot of work
as you point out they have to do now the
defense still very good
but who's the running back going to be
who's the center going to be are they
going to draft for guys who can be
plugged right in and play now are they
going to be looking for the best
available talent that they can develop
over the long haul maybe into 2022 23
and beyond
they really are giving off the vibe of a
team that is win now win now win now and
i suspect their draft is going to
reflect that
even if they may be passing on guys who
could become better contributors over
the long haul
mike the steelers never have been one of
those teams that says
let's take a step back this year maybe
next year as well and we're going to
come back as a championship contender in
2023. they never have been that way i
don't think under the rooney's that they
ever will be that way and so that's why
what happened doesn't surprise me at all
but
it also
tells you exactly
what they think of mason rudolph
and what they think in a very limited
exposure what they think of dwayne
haskins
you know they're totally unsure that
these guys can be the long-term guys and
mike they are in no position
to draft any of the top five
quarterbacks this year
so
you know it's
it's to me it's not remotely surprising
they brought back roethlisberger it is
in their dna
to think in march
that
if the following things go right
we have a chance to play in the super
bowl this year and that's what they
think
art rooney stating the obvious yesterday
when he said we've got to be a lot
better in running the ball they were
32nd in the nfl now there are different
accounts and theories on whether or not
ben roethlisberger was calling audibles
too often or with rpo plays choosing to
pass when he should have maybe handed
off but something jerome bettis told ed
bouchetta the athletic during the season
that still resonates with me it just has
to be a full offensive commitment to the
run it has to start in training camp it
has to continue all year it's a
mentality for your offensive line it's
firing off the ball and knocking guys on
their butts and opening holes so it is a
combination of offensive line having the
running back who can get it done and the
quarterback who buys in to the point
where he won't change the plays
to pass plays because it became just a
litany of short pass short pass short
pass short pass for the steelers last
year they've got to get back to the
running game that is their identity
peter i've said before this off season
they need to find not that it's easy to
do but there are
impactful running backs available in the
draft every year they need a guy who can
make a frank o'hara's type of an impact
back in 72 when he as a rookie he came
in and and he was the best running back
one of the best running backs in the nfl
immediately they need a guy that they
can trust to come in and get it done
right out of the gates as a rookie
because it's not like they have anyone
like that on the roster
hey look they thought james connor was
going to be that guy but he was always
nicked up and
look
he had the ethos that they wanted he had
the physical brand of football that they
wanted
but every year was there were two or
three things that kept him from being in
his best right away when he was got
drafted it was his hamstring
uh but but so i agree totally with you
mike i think they have drafted a bunch
of guys who were meh running backs they
just you know they they've they've been
to me
much below average
they need
a workhorse they need to do what uh
you know what
they need to find in the later rounds or
in the middle rounds because i just i
wouldn't use a running uh a pick on a
running back early but they need to find
a james robinson or a uh you know a
kareem hunt
playing type um you know third round or
after in this draft they've got too many
needs to fill early
uh in my opinion anyway to to take a
running back in the first or second
round
you mentioned james connor too he became
a free agent
11 days ago
officially nine days ago this is the
first time his name's been mentioned as
far as i know in this discussion about
what he failed to do in pittsburgh it's
been crickets and a lot of the running
backs are doing short-term deals one
year two-year but his name hasn't come
up as even a guy who's on anyone's radar
screen so maybe he slinks back to the
steelers the way juju smith schuster did
let me ask you that before we move on
how surprised were you that the dominoes
fell in a way that brought juju back to
a place where he had made it clear his
opinion was he wouldn't be back and he
was telling his teammates he wouldn't be
back
he just you know 2021
uh messed with juju smith schuster's
plans
and
you know what i found very telling about
it mike
is that you look at kenny galladay
and maybe kenny galladay said to the
giants the giants probably said okay
look we you know we'd like to uh we'd
like to do a lot less money we you know
blah blah blah we're going to give you
some security but we're going to be at
13 million a year on average or whatever
it is and so kenny goliday easily easily
could have said to the giants hey look
i'm going to go somewhere else and make
one year 17
and then just go into free agency again
next year
and that to me
is exactly
juju smith shuster
not the jets not anybody
had it in their mind that he's a 15
million 16 million dollar player over a
number of years in a difficult salary
cap era maybe two years ago
when everybody was it was you know high
on life and and the caps going up 10
million every year maybe two years ago a
juju smith schuster could have gotten
four years 65 million
but he's not getting that in this
environment because i believe and this
is just
look
look at this the one stat up there
okay 97 catches last year wonderful
8.6 a catch okay nobody really views him
the way they view kenny gallaudet kenny
gallaudet is viewed as a downfield
threat
juju smith schuster now has become at
least in the eyes of many people around
the league sort of a larry fitzgerald
possession receiver
and so maybe he's not that and maybe
he's physically gifted enough
to be
uh you know that deep downfield threat
again but you just haven't seen it in
the pittsburgh offense they have chosen
others to be that
you mentioned two years ago that he
would have gotten that kind of money and
the other reason that's accurate two
years ago we didn't know he wasn't
capable of being a number one guy and
that's the reality after antonio brown
was traded they tried to make him the
number one guy he doesn't have the
downfield speed to draw double coverage
and be the focal point of the passing
attack he is a number two and as a
number two there's a limit on what he's
ever going to make pandemic or no
pandemic affecting the salary cap
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports